[Music]
did you guys
hear about 46
what and then 47. oh our next two
presents 48
he's in the hundreds now you know that
right is he yeah oh my god
101 he did it like
100 200 300.
oh he's just skipping now yeah he's
scared wow
tell us about this this story here has
nothing to do with numbers
but it does have to do with jake paul
yeah about jake paul
i heard about jake paul so this fool's
house got raided
by the phoebe damn dude look at him hey
oh i get it
he looks like uh a white guy that
started hanging out with colombian drug
lords
and he's like i'm one of them i think he
has a way more punchable face than you
do
thank you i think so too wow thank you i
don't even think you have a face
[ __ ] boy in the dictionary it's probably
him not his brother
true like if you if you stand logan
and uh jake next to each other right who
has the stronger fuckboy feel
i think logan punches his brother in the
face
he's like [ __ ] this guy oh she's my
brother but hey his new song
wasn't bad he has a new song he's good
he does music jake paul
jake paul he's been rapping for a while
you don't remember every day bro it's
everyday every day
[Laughter]
steve is over there i would hate to be a
new viewer
i'm like what the [ __ ] yeah he put out a
new song recently
his old stuff is one but the new and
people were saying he didn't write
he didn't write it because it's so good
oh he has a ghostwriter uh it's it's not
bad but his delivery is good too his
name is
yeah her stuff is pretty cool anyway so
jake
his house got raided and people were
looking into it they're like wait why
did his house get raided it was like
a really dramatic scene there was like
swat team and everything
and there were photos of the cops
leaving the home
with firearms in their hands so people
were thinking like wait is it does this
have to do with firearms somehow like is
he
i don't know illegal firearms yeah he's
gun running somehow
something i don't know what is it and
finally law enforcement
or they were telling sources or like
people that they were actually raiding
his place in connection
to the looting that happened in arizona
so we talked about this before too
we're in the blm thing yeah during the
protest there were
some looting happening in scottsdale
arizona
at this one mall and so that's where
like jake was filming all of this too so
i'm gonna show you guys
so he crossed state borders to go there
and join looting that's what it seemed
like
i don't know why was he even there
scottsdale i don't know yeah i don't
know either
but this is some footage of the stuff
that the fbi is looking into and they're
investigating because of this footage
[Music]
oh [ __ ] not the p of change
oh my god that makes it a hate crime
yeah
so this footage of him being inside of
the mall after it was already closed
down
is like the reason why he got charged
with trespassing yeah
but what blows my mind is why is this a
fbi investigation that requires
a raid right right yeah it's crazy so
you don't think it's this really
uh well is it cover-up story well the
media or what the fbi has released
is is it's in connection to this
but the thing is um
they can't disclose the it's on ongoing
investigations they can't disclose
but the weird thing to me is that they
also raided his buddy with a
pepto-bismol house
yeah he was a convicted pimp pooh buddy
yes okay
yep so that that well before we get to
the the pimp dude
just really quick this is these are
photos of the fbi
at jake's calabasas god damn
that's his house man let me tell you
something
these [ __ ] got money bro i went
to uh i was at
i went to logan's house to because
that's where they do his podcast and
it's on like a [ __ ] i was like this
[ __ ] crazy this has to be like 10
million
yeah like no i know those guys made like
20 30 mil
or more just on ad revenue and then they
had merch and all that so like they're
making
crazy bucks individually and then one of
them was on the disney channel too
before yeah this one the whole army was
there
yeah yeah it's weird like it's extra
holy [ __ ] do they have enough money to
pay the army to show them at their
doorstep just to create like
fake news oh probably it's like [ __ ]
extra oh yeah
these are the guns that they they were
carrying yeah like three guns right like
they make it seem like they had a whole
arsenal of weapons i don't know well the
media is gonna
like obviously exaggerate and so they
were end up saying that
like no this is not in connection to the
firearms anyway
like it's just the fact that he has
firearms in his home
and for that reason we're required to
confiscate them
apparently well because it's not um
stowed in a
in a legal way yeah it stowed like
scarface way
above his bathtub right here jesus damn
they also mentioned that jake wasn't
present like the lawyer mentioned that
he was out of state
so we don't know where and so out of
state jake he was looting at another
state
i know right how sick is it to have a
house that big and be like nah i'm not
staying there this weekend
oh that's so sad i know this is pretty
sick though sick imagine having a house
that big and your brother also has a
house that
big damn and you both have your own
businesses how'd you like to be the
third paul brother
is there a third paw brother third you
guys don't know about the third part
he's a software guy just really
kicks it keeps it casual it makes about
70 a year are you [ __ ] me is there a
third yeah
really i know you're like i don't
believe it because well you know because
because you filmed with logan so i'm i'm
i'm assuming you you but you're also
troll no peter paul
you're lying no peter paul yeah and he's
just doing seriously i've met him yeah
he's just a regular ass children's ring
the guy does software you're live
no i'm serious he's he older or younger
or what where he's younger yeah
he's younger yeah he's younger than both
of them all wait hold on because
jake paul is 23 or something like that
you're saying a 22 year old he's a boy
genius
[ __ ] steve dude no
the giveaway was peter paul
i was like come on guys
and on top of that like he needs to have
a douche name
logan jake should have been like chad
paul
tip you know the manning brothers have a
third manning too though i don't even
know who the
cooper manning oh the football man i
just knew one of them
no there's peyton eli so they're the
jake and logan and then
uh cooper is the third that's true
anyway
back to this so yeah they did raid
a second home in vegas
he has been allegedly accused of being a
pimp because i thought he was
convicted yes that's why but no it's for
pandering
which is like the legal term for pimping
but the way they write it is like he's
big pimping pretty much a pimp big
pandarens
it didn't work as well didn't work as
well yeah so then
here's a photo of the two of them
together and so he's also a nun
he's a pope come on when i first saw the
picture i thought
he would he looked like chum from um uh
the [ __ ]
pawn stars pawn stars yeah yeah so this
is his home
my friend lives in your hair oh really
yeah he sent me pictures of it he goes
yeah that's logan paul's buddies that's
a house
yeah it's like a pepto-bismol house that
looks weird dude his neighbors are
pissed
while the raid was happening or that
that same day it's fantastic
or he was filming trying to graffiti up
this whole
place as barbie and so they had girls
there with like bikinis
and just like uh spray painting this
whole place to be a barbie's house
so i'm gonna play a a clip of that
morning because then he ended up posting
on his stories and he talks about it
here we go well had a rough morning
get it you guys are really concerned
about the raid that went down at my
house
meanwhile we got a mansion to paint the
barbies in here and you know
we got work to do unreal
a lot of people talking trash a lot of
people making up things
online today i'm not going to get into
any details other than to tell you
the only thing they wanted to know about
was arizona
yeah right it's pretty overkill to
have so much like it's a it's a
nationwide
like it's like a raid for
logan paul and all of his associates
right yeah because that guy in the
background
arizona like like breaking into a mall
oh too weird because then that dude was
saying
or the the hype man that you saw in the
video during
an interview with the media he was
saying that they were looking for
someone who resides in california
so pretty much saying that they the fbi
went and raided that place because they
were looking for
jake well jacob jacob jacob paul yeah so
that's crazy it's it's it's i don't know
like i mean
if if a celebrity went through this
right i
like wouldn't they do it discreetly
because they don't want
like if will smith was under something
like they're not going to come in with
the whole [ __ ] national guard yeah i
don't know what the real motive is
because
if they wanted jake paul himself they
would have waited till he was there
like people are running surveillance 24
7. there's someone parked in the car
just staring okay [ __ ] jake's here
now okay now let's bring everyone in so
the fact that they raided jake uh the
house when jake wasn't there they did
that on purpose
yeah they wanted him to not be there
yeah because he's missing because he has
guns though
probably because of that so it's like
what's the purpose of why why the entire
army
you know wouldn't just a couple agents
be suffice
maybe because it was like the house is
so big when we run this search there's
no way we could do it with five people
dude
yeah they don't know if he has an army
rory was like
or was like no because the jake paul
army they have to watch out for them
right yeah
their name doesn't he call his people
army no the jake paulers
well doesn't he have like an entourage
of people who drink a lot of energy
drinks and [ __ ] and
like yeah or what if it was like five of
the guys were going to the raid and
their the the other army dudes like oh
you go to jake paul's house can i go
and they're all fans and stuff and
they're like dude
[Applause]
and they're all like [ __ ] there's
nothing else to do
let's do it that's probably why i was
just going to the battlefield you guys
going jake paul's house
it's on the way and then the other one
was like oh [ __ ] you're going to the
pimp's house
dude there's probably a lot of girls huh
let's do it i heard that they're going
to have a photo shoot with like
20 girls that all right [ __ ] out let's
go and then so they're all planning this
day
to raid them when there's 20 girls there
that's like pictures of soldiers in iraq
with saddam's gold have you seen all
that [ __ ]
and they're in like saddam's mansion and
is in his jacuzzi and [ __ ] like
[ __ ] like dude also recently he was
he was
throwing a gigantic mansion party during
this pandemic was he
yeah that's that was on the news yeah
that wasn't
in july oh mr jake pauler jake paul
yeah dom dude yeah there was just a
whole bunch of people there no one's
wearing masks well everyone quarantined
for two weeks before the party
they were checking temperature at the
door wait doesn't he also have a boxing
match coming up he does
yeah oh where's he fighting uh nate
robinson
the basketball player oh that's right i
just i saw that it's so
[ __ ] random i don't know just for fun
for money
that's why well i thought i mean like i
mean like uh it was there beef or some
story behind it i don't know the story
but it's just so random that these two
are even gonna be facing each other yeah
that's tight yeah so everyone's just
waiting
to see like what is what is he gonna say
because as of right now
there has only been statements from his
lawyer so nothing's come out of
jake himself this is some crazy [ __ ]
that's a lot that's this looks like a
mafia takedown thing
yeah and once we find out it was like
for three stolen
items maybe the youtube [ __ ] is all just
a drug front
you know what i'm saying oh yeah but
he's already making mad money
where is he what are we involved with
nobody thinks we're that involved
we don't have a house like that no
nobody thinks that well one of us do
no none of us have close to that not
even close no
to the pet even the pepto-bismol house
not even no yeah
hello guys thank you guys so much for
watching all of our videos and i know
it's been a million years in the making
but we finally got
just kidding news merch yep so make sure
you go down to the store below
and you can bring around wow yeah you
can get a piece
of jk news and thank you guys for
supporting thank you
[Music]
bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you